YURI GRINSHTEYN: Google acquired
Stackdriver back in 2014,
and the suite of operations
tools in Google Cloud
has come a very
long way since then.
Today, cloud monitoring is built
right into the Cloud Console,
and I'm here to show you how
to set up and use monitoring
in your cloud projects.
This is the Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With the integration
of monitoring features
into the Cloud Console, you'll
notice that the Stackdriver
brand is gone.
But the functionality
you've come to depend on
isn't changing.
You'll still be able to use all
of the features you're used to.
Let's take a look at
those, and what's new.
Let's start by
selecting monitoring
from the products menu.
Instead of opening the
Stackdriver UI in a new window,
you get a new, better design
UI right in the console.
Note that you can still
select or configure
the workspace in this new UI.
The concept of
workspaces and using them
to aggregate monitoring data
across multiple projects
hasn't changed.
Workspaces and
their host projects
are still how you
create and retain
monitoring configuration data.
Let's take a look at the core
features of cloud monitoring.
We'll start by setting up
a VM and deploying a web
server on it.
From there, we'll install
the monitoring agent,
set up an uptime check,
and configure a dashboard
to show us the health
of our new service.
We'll put the link to the full
steps in the episode notes
so you can easily follow along.
Start by creating a compute
engine virtual machine
by going to the products menu
and selecting Compute Engine.
From there, create
a new instance.
You can leave most
options at default.
Once the instance is created,
use the SSH functionality
in the console to
open a secure terminal
session to your new VM.
We're going to use
this to do two things--
install the Apache web server
and install the monitoring
agent.
First run sudo apt-get
update and sudo apt-get
install apache php to get
the latest package versions,
and install Apache.
Then, run these two commands
to download and install
the monitoring agent.
Now that the
environment is set up,
we're ready to configure
cloud monitoring.
Let's first create
an uptime check
that will monitor
our web service
and potentially notify
us if there's a problem.
From the Products
menu, select Monitoring
and go to Uptime Checks.
Create a new one.
You'll need to give the
machine's external IP address
to enter as the target here.
Test the check before saving
it to make sure everything
is configured properly.
Note that this IP address
is ephemeral by default
and may change.
You may want to assign a static
IP address to this machine,
if this is a service with
external users or consumers.
From here, let's
configure a dashboard
so we can easily visualize the
health of our small service.
We can include charts
showing us the availability
and performance of
our uptime check
and charts showing us
infrastructure utilization
to get a complete picture.
Go to Products,
select Monitoring,
and click on Dashboards.
Then create a new dashboard.
To add a chart showing
uptime check failures,
select Uptime Check
URL as the resource,
and check Past as the metric.
Filter the data through just the
uptime check you just created
and use the Count False
aggregator to only show you
failures.
Once you've saved
this chart, you
can follow a similar
process to add other charts
to your dashboard.
You might want to
include a chart showing
the performance of your
service as reflected
by the uptime check
latency metric.
You can also include
charts showing
your resource utilization
of your infrastructure.
Looking at metrics like
CPU utilization of your VM
is a great place to start.
One of the new features
that's being made available
with this release is
the Dashboards API.
You'll now be able to automate
the creation of dashboards
in your workspaces
and generally automate
more of your monitoring setup.
We'll come back to
dashboard and monitoring
automation in future episodes.
Once your monitoring
is setup, you'll
probably want alerting
to get notified
if the service goes down.
Since we've already
set up the monitoring,
we can create a
new alerting policy
by clicking on it in the menu.
We can set our uptime
check as the resource type,
and set the metric to
make sure that it passes,
then set up an
email notification.
If you want to see more
details on how to set it up,
check out the link
below to the earlier
video we did on alerting.
That wraps up our intro
to cloud monitoring
and our tour of
its new integration
in the Cloud Console.
We created a service,
configured a dashboard
to show us its
health, and set up
alerting to let us know
if it has any issues.
You are now ready to start
using cloud monitoring
in your own environment.
I hope you are as excited about
the future of cloud monitoring
and these new features as I am.
That's it for this episode.
Come back next time,
when we take a look
at what's new in cloud logging.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]